what would happen if you forced yourself
to think only positive thoughts would it
improve your happiness
or is this a terrible idea after trying
it out for the last three days i learned
a surprising lesson that changed the way
i think the rules are simple if i notice
any negative thoughts i'll interrupt
them
and instead pump out some positive ones
i just woke up and i feel amazing but
today is going to be an incredible day
but take decisive action
get so much done i'll start with
meditating i think this is going to be
more challenging than i thought
because the interesting part is noticing
when you have a negative thought and
coming up with a
positive one but i definitely feel
better than i usually do
there seem to be two camps when it comes
to positive thinking
those who believe it's the key to a
happier healthier and more successful
life with countless of studies proving
that
point and those who believe that you
have to be realistic and being too
positive is
actually toxic also with many studies
back in their position
but what if both of them are wrong
according to several studies
by putting on a fake smile your brain
receives positive signals that actually
make you feel better and one study even
found that people with botox injections
that made it harder for them to frown
were also happier that's because our
physiology facial expressions
posture how we breathe doesn't just
reflect how we feel
but also causes us to feel a certain way
[Applause]
well great this shirt needs to be washed
anyways alright time for a cold shower
i love cold showers is it dangerous to
just
tell yourself certain things even if
they're not true
[Music]
because up until this point i felt good
until i didn't
i feel great i feel great i feel great
i don't know what it is but for some
reason i've been i've been in an
emotional
it's weird i'm trying to be positive i'm
trying to feel good i'm trying to feel
pumped and
empowered and i'm gonna decide that
today is gonna be a great day
but it seemed like the more i tried the
worse it got
it's quite challenging to just force
positive thoughts right now i don't know
it just feels like there's
internal stress like whenever i try to
hype myself up and just think positive
it just pulls me back down more so being
positive all the time might actually be
a bad idea when it actually makes you
feel worse
this study for example published in 2009
showed that people with
low self-esteem if they told themselves
i'm a lovable person
it actually made it worse because if you
don't believe the positive thoughts that
you tell yourself it just makes it worse
because it confirms
it's not true and now i'm even trying
hard and it's so silly and i also know
that
emotions want to be heard and
acknowledged and if you suppress them or
you ignore them
they just bubble up even more because
they're there for a reason it seems like
an important key is congruence
our inside world the emotions that we
feel has to be
acknowledged in the outside world it's
the same feeling that you get when
you're at a party and you have some
social anxiety and then someone asks you
how are you and you're like great and
meanwhile you feel like punching a hole
in the wall
that's incongruence and a lot of the
things that i told myself
just didn't make sense logically and
deep down i knew they weren't true
i'll be honest i went into this thinking
like this whole toxic positivity thing
it's just from people who are pessimists
but i'm feeling it
i'm feeling it it's day two i'm feeling
good and
today i want to take a bit of a
different approach and this is where
reframing comes in
it's basically a way to challenge the
thoughts that we have around certain
events
experiences emotions but it's completely
rational and based in reality
for example this morning i woke up
feeling a bit depressed
and even a little hopeless you know when
you wake up and you just
why are we still here just to suffer and
instead of just lying to myself and
telling myself i feel great
i just said i don't feel good that's
fine i know i can feel better later and
i can still have
a really amazing day 100 based in
reality believable to
me and also optimistic this way no
matter how i felt or what i thought
i could spin it into an optimistic frame
without feeling like i'm faking it
i haven't worked out in a while so i
probably will be a bit weaker but it's
actually awesome because now i can see
more improvement again
i can get back to where i was do some
heavy squats
i would stop every so often to check in
with myself to notice any negative
attitudes
to see what thoughts are causing them
and sometimes i have to get really
creative to come up with
an empowering response i don't like
doing emails but i know i'll feel so
free afterwards because it's finally off
my plate
so maybe i could even be excited about
that yeah
yeah why not yeah yeah and technically
you can put a positive frame
on everything this is where the camp off
realists would pick up their pitchforks
and be like hey wait a second
stop stop stop stop stop sometimes
things are just bad you can't just put a
positive spin on everything
you gotta face reality face reality how
would you face reality in this scenario
at 6 pm on december 10 1914 and a
massive explosion erupts in west orange
new jersey
10 factory buildings catch fire and you
thomas edison legendary inventor
watch as your work is destroyed by the
flames did he face reality
yes the reality is the buildings burned
down 23 million
damage occurred the flames consuming
years of priceless records and
prototypes you're 67 years old and these
are all
facts that can't be argued with nobody
would blame you if you said
it's over for me and some might even
call that facing reality
but that's not reality that's just an
interpretation
of the facts here's how thomas edison
faced reality while watching the flames
he told a son
go get your mother and all her friends
they'll never see a fire like this again
we've just got rid of a lot of rubbish
see there's an infinite way to interpret
this reality it's over
it's a setback it's inconvenient it's a
fresh start so
thomas edison took out a loan of 10
million dollars immediately started
rebuilding it without firing any of his
employees and made 10 million dollars
the following year if there's an
infinite amount of ways to interpret
this event why not choose the one
that is most empowering and when you
give yourself permission to just
for a bit purely focus on what's moving
you forward
you notice how much our thoughts affect
our reality
and you get these weird moments of just
euphoria
if this became a conscious consistent
habit it would be life-changing
no doubt i want to challenge you if
you're watching this just go for a
15-minute walk
and while you're walking tell yourself
i'm gonna think only positive thoughts
i'm gonna think about how lucky i am how
grateful i am how
excited i am for life even if you can't
find reasons right off the bat
find them and just put on a smile and
once you're in a good mood
you automatically come up with better
thoughts it becomes easier you build
momentum you get it to an upward spiral
but before all the good vibes only
people and the positivity camp by
getting too excited i really think there
are times where
negative thinking is not just helpful
but actually necessary
think about the dude who smokes a pack a
day never puts on a seatbelt
and never uses condoms and he's just
like don't worry about it
and next thing you know boom dead with
five children or a more common example
maybe that friend who keeps saying that
she will eventually write that book that
she keeps talking about but
three years later she still hasn't
written a single page
i will do it eventually tomorrow these
people need
some fear and doubt what if 10 years go
by
and you still haven't done anything how
would you feel then in that sense
negative thinking can be a really
powerful tool day three was the final
day of the experiment and it was much
easier now that i
allowed myself to think negative
thoughts as long as i reframe them into
something positive day three
woke up feeling pretty stressed because
of the upcoming video projects
but just talking myself into confidence
and like hey this is gonna work out hey
you gotta crush it hey this is gonna be
so successful and
actively getting excited about it just
helps a ton
i realized once again how hot i am on
myself and this default focus i have on
the negative for example today i
called myself a few times comparing
myself to people who are younger than me
that have achieved 10 times more
and i'm like damn it what am i doing
wrong instead of saying
wow look at them that means i can do it
too and being inspired rather than
feeling beaten down i think this focus
on the negative is something i developed
early in my life and it actually helped
me a lot when starting my first business
i considered myself to be a realist i
felt like i had the courage to
look at how things really were and
looking at your weaknesses
is crucial for improvement it got to a
point where
any positive thing that i saw i found a
way to reframe it into something
negative
and i got more and more into that
thinking and i was miserable
until it became so unbearable that i had
so little joy in my
life that's when i realized that i
wasn't a realist
that's what i was telling myself i was a
pessimist and it wasn't because i was
courageous enough to look at how things
really were it's because i was terrified
of getting my hopes up and being let
down i was just afraid
it's almost like i kept myself at the
very bottom because i was afraid that if
i climbed up
i would end up at the bottom super smart
thinking
[Music]
now with day three coming to an end i
can tell you it's harder than you think
but it's always interesting to
experiment with different ways of
thinking
and seeing how it affects our experience
it's like 10
is facts and the other 90 is literally
just
made up to settle the debate between the
two camps that are both
just effective for some people some of
the time i learned that there is a third
camp that i think is
always ideal and that's the camp of
effective thinkers who always
think in a way that helps them move
towards what they truly want in life
taking the best from both sides whenever
they need to i challenge you to try it
out for one day and see what you find
youtube thinks you'd really like this
video here too so go check it out i put
a lot of work into all my videos so i'm
sure you'll like it i'll see you over
there
thanks for watching